- Welcome back, y'all.
(audience applauds)
Many of you grew up loving our next guest,
with his good friend Kenan Thompson
in shows like "All That"
and "Kenan & Kel" on Nickelodeon,
as well as movies like "Good Burger."
Well, now they're back.
That's right, "Good Burger 2" is out now,
and you can see it on Paramount+.
- Water?
- I think so, lemme see.
(gentle jazz music)
Hm (swirls), hm,
hm, hm? (gargles)
(spits) Oh yeah, that's water.
- None for me, thanks.
(wind whooshes)
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- Say hello to Kel Mitchell!
(upbeat rock music)
- I have to say-
- [Kel] New York!
- I know, I love it here.
- Right, look at you!
- The energy is so me.
(Kel laughs)
I have to ask though,
you had a health scare
recently, which was crazy.
- I did.
- But you're good now, right?
- I'm good now-
- But for a minute you felt
like you were like paralyzed, right?
- Was that what I-
- Yeah, I had a pinched nerve
that took out the whole
right side of my body,
and it was definitely a scare,
'cause it was like, "Oh, this
could be something worse."
But I did MRI, I did all of that,
and all I could say is,
God is good, I'm good.
I cleared all of that.
(audience applauds)
I'm good!
- Isn't it crazy?
The unknown is what freaks me out.
- Yeah!
- The unknown.
I'm like, "What's happening in there?"
- Anyway-
- Man!
- So comedy, as a kid,
who are your influences?
'Cause you're hilarious.
- Oh man, Martin Lawrence.
- Oh my god, love him.
- Richard Pryor.
- Yeah.
- John Ritter, the list goes on and on-
- "Three's Company," okay, yeah.
- "Three's Company," yeah.
- I love it, yeah.
- I love John Ritter.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, man!
- I love Martin Lawrence too, man.
He had such a great show.
- Martin Lawrence is amazing,
you see that a lot in my comedy. (laughs)
- I was gonna say, yeah, you're so funny,
and innately witty, you and Kenan.
And I'm always like,
"What did y'all grow up on
"that you ended up just
morphing into these beings
"that make people laugh
everywhere you go?"
- Yeah, also my family too,
and the people around me in Chicago.
A lot of my characters are based on that,
even one of my coaches.
- Do they hate that or love that?
- Oh, well, I had a coach
that was after me (laughs)
(audience laughs)
'cause I had a character
called Coach Kreeton,
and it was based on a coach in Chicago
and he was just mean all the time.
It could be Valentine's,
(audience laughs)
and he'd be like, "I
don't care about no love."
"Sit down, shut up!"
(Kelly laughs)
He was loud like that.
- I had a coach like that.
- Yeah!
And I was like,
"What is wrong with you?"
- "Run laps!"
You're feeling sad, they're like, "Run,
"it'll make you feel better."
No it won't.
(audience laughs)
It will not, actually.
- Right!
- I hear another one
of your influences, though,
was George Clinton, right?
- George, oh come on, now,
Parliament-Funkadelic?
(audience cheers)
You know what I mean?
Oh, hey! (laughs)
And my dad had all the records.
He had a little man cave in the basement
in Chicago.
- Love it.
- And he had all those records,
and I would listen to all of them.
And then in "Good Burger" 1,
I got to meet George Clinton
and do the big dance scene.
And he's in part two, too.
Yeah, yeah, we got him back.
- He had to get back.
- He's in "Good Burger 2," yeah.
- Do y'all improvise a lot?
I feel like, 'cause Kenan,
y'all gotta be used to it at this point.
You've had such a relationship
established for so long.
- Oh, yes.
- Do you improvise a ton?
- A ton, and then we we're
using the same writers
from the first one,
so they know that we're gonna improvise.
And so we do that all the time.
(audience laughs)
Oh, look at us!
(all laugh)
- The babies.
- Our first day
of "Good Burger 2," it
was super, super funny,
'cause Keenan just kept laughing
with me with the wig on,
he couldn't take, 'cause
we've been around each other
with the beards and everything,
and he's just looking at me, (laughs)
he can't take it.
We laughed through the whole thing.
Can't take it seriously.
(audience laughs)
- It was the longest first day ever,
'cause we just kept cracking up
at every time I said anything.
It was just-
- He's like,
"Nope, can't take it."
- "Nope, I can't take it.
"Look at how Kel looks." (laughs)
- "You look ridiculous,"
it's like he's thinking.
Do people ask y'all to rate their burgers?
- Yes, all the time.
- I imagine.
- I am the Burger King.
(audience laughs)
- The original
- Original.
- The original BK.
- When we go anywhere,
five star-
♪ Have it your way ♪
- Drive through, whatever.
They'll give us free burgers,
it's awesome.
- That's amazing,
they give you free burgers?
- Yeah.
- What a great life.
- It's. (laughs)
- Yeah!
Look, I'm-
- Anyone wants a burger?
- Once a poor kid, always a poor kid.
Free-95 is always acceptable.
(Kel laughs)
What's your favorite burger place?
- Okay, so-
- Do you have one here?
- I don't have a favorite here,
so y'all gotta tell me
what's the favorite one here.
But in LA I wanted to do
something to give back.
We had National Food Service
Day this past September,
and I wanted to give back
to mom and pop places and burger places.
And so I started showcasing
'em on my social media,
started rating them
and also giving them a good burger review,
and then I also tipped
the cashier in the front,
'cause Ed is a cashier.
So I tipped them and then we went
to over, like, 20 different spots in LA.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, it's been really good.
- Did you have a favorite?
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
- If I go anywhere,
where should I go?
Do you have a favorite?
- Okay, so,
I love them all,
'cause I don't want them to get mad at me.
So I love them all.
But it's one spot called
Billionaire Burger Boyz.
- Billionaire Burger Boyz.
- Billionaire Burger Boyz,
and they have a lobster burger.
A lobster burger,
and the lobster, just,
(audience oohs and aahs)
the tail hanging out the burger.
Look at that tail out the burger,
look at that there.
It tastes so good, y'all.
- Woo!
- That woman like, "Oh,
I don't know about that,"
but it's good.
- I know about it.
- It looks intimidating,
but it's really good.
It is really good.
- No, smush it down,
take a bite.
- You smush it down.
It's all about the good-
- Jason's with you,
he clapped, my MD was like, "Yes."
- You know about it?
- Yes.
- Down in Compton, right?
- Yeah.
There you go. (claps)
- Oh my gosh.
- You know what's happening.
- Now I just want a burger.
- Mac and cheese barbecue.
- Oh the mac and cheese-
- Mac and cheese barbecue?
- [Kel] Oh, you do know what's happening!
(Jason laughs)
- Oh, I want it now.
Let's take a quick commercial break.
Be sure to check out "Good Burger 2,"
streaming on Paramount+.